[Music]
hey welcome to JK news today we were
talking about how Bernie Sanders is
getting completely [ __ ] over by the
DNC oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah are you
serious
so why did he get [ __ ] over before Jo
because Hillary what did she do she uh
[ __ ] it wasn't the emails I forgot well
right so so basically continuing the
agenda and Bernie is not well the DNC
was internally talking [ __ ] on Bernie
and me and they were diverting money
away from his campaign using his Hillary
campaign and and Hillary was basically
the DNC was in debt and Hillary's
campaign was picking up a tab for that
debt and allocating money to that
supports her campaign her candidates and
not Bernie people that make sense
Oh last year's primaries right this was
this was 2016 right 2016 and then the
email leaks also proved that she was
colluding with the President or the not
the president but the the top of the
committee of the DNC the was canceled
right and and they uh they were planning
openly to shut him out yes and they also
fed debate questions that were pre known
by Hillary Clinton which Donna Brazile
admitted to later she was later the head
of the DNC and she took over after
everywhere okay so the same things
happening again to biryeo that's what oh
the guy that leaked that information get
killed
oh well no that's what people that's
that's what that's what that's a
conspiracy theory about no but that's
what that's but nobody really I mean do
oh that's not like confirm [ __ ] oh this
is confirm [ __ ]
this is confirmed we were talking
conspiracy well we're kind of gonna get
there we're gonna kind of get there well
not exactly that's not really what I'm
getting
so Bernie is getting [ __ ] by the DNC
again because did you guys see what
happened the other night during the DNC
debate the one with him in Warren no
problem okay so basically CNN opens the
debate by so a new story had come out
that Elizabeth Warren says that Bernie
Sanders told her pride
hey I don't think a woman could get
elected president to her right as a way
to discourage her kind of thing and
Bernie says I never said that okay so
they opened the debate and they
basically say hey Bernie did you or did
you not tell Elizabeth Warren that a
woman could never get elected president
he said I did not okay right so then
they code then they go to Elizabeth
Warren immediately and say hey Elizabeth
how did you feel when Bernie told you a
woman couldn't be like the president now
how [ __ ] up is that they led the
question like that and then like said
Bernie up and then they basically just
said Bernie lied immediately then you're
responsible thing was that the reporter
rather than saying what do you think
about like what if he said it right
rather than treating as a question the
reporter was stating it as a fact
exactly we definitely said it and
there's proof which is more proof that
CNN is [ __ ] trash and and that news
right I mean they're trash dude that I
like the way that they did that they
angled that was obviously coordinated
than watches CNN and believes it anymore
I don't know but people obviously do I
mean they have crazy lives so [ __ ]
much so that's what's frustrating here
for people who are watching this because
Bernie it seems will not stand up for
himself and say that's what they did is
[ __ ] up or he won't really I mean he
he won't lead the charge about how this
sucks right so a lot of it seems like
they're [ __ ] with I mean they're
[ __ ] up within their own group right
and people might say that that is a
conspiracy oh you're saying that CNN
coordinated it's like yeah well they did
it in 2016 CNN definitely did it for the
views cuz he timed it and released it
before the debate but they are there
also have other witnesses to the
conversation have come out and said that
he said that well but his argument is
that he didn't say that women can't be
President but then the other people are
saying that what you said was a woman
can't be Trump and those are kind of two
different arguments that they're both
tiny but like also in the same
conversation he also came out in the 70s
and said that he thought a woman could
be President no yeah that's his argument
yeah but other people's argument is
saying it's not so much as woman
becoming president in general it's all
about a woman beating Trump and those
are two different conversation yeah I
think that being put into one Congress
but I think
so he might have just been seeing like
basically like with this climate and the
people that are actively voting I'm not
sure that a woman could be elected but
then it's like what are you trying to
say Bernie
Lizabeth warrants an right but she's
saying well she that is what you told me
I couldn't really easy to take that out
and like the way the climate is right
now to throw that on the ether and be
like look what he said it's you know but
it's a typical smear campaign is very
typical and it's a coordinated smear
campaign which is what the Bernie fans
are pissed off about
yeah because also his fans are like the
people that are his fans it's like they
don't know what to say I'm sorry cuz
it's just like it's [ __ ] annoying
that's what it's so i well my question
is is like who is CNN backing because if
they're willing to go against Bernie
Warren nor Biden war nor Biden to be
that way as far I mean they hadn't
pulled a stunt like that on them well
cuz I know Biden is of the old guard but
Warren I don't know much about her so
what's up with you cutting or Tulsi
Gabbard they got drowned out in both
countries
yeah well told Tulsi she I think she
officially exited yangste Oh in the game
though it's just that like the the big
conspiracy against him is that many
polls show that he should have had
enough backing to be in this debate but
CNN chose specific polls that he didn't
have enough in and that's the big
problem so if you choose a Monmouth poll
instead of a Pew poll or so that that's
wholly them saying that's how they
that's how people are saying that they
iced
Tulsi and yang out and and that's what
people are pissed about right that they
feel like the DNC is picking their
favorites instead of letting the votes
decide and no votes have been counted
yeah here we go here's the real
conspiracy boughs okay all of this is
just out here to drown out any other
competitor other than Trump it's all
Trump doing all of this because he wants
to get elected again
he's just driving what's he doing though
so he needs all him all of that you've
seen in everything it's a sexy good
spirit it's a horny conspiracy cuz
Bernie actually has a shot at beating
anyone
trumpchi says let's drown them all out
they're all terrible they're all bad
decisions so that at the end of the day
once again yes you know it's funny
officially impeach now called out CNN
though so why would his mortal enemy
because he's in anything - what's funny
though is that Trump actually just
tweeted in defense of Bernie saying that
the DNC is clearly [ __ ] burning again
and then Bernie came out and [ __ ] on
Trump for that he's like he's protecting
CNN basically [ __ ] him over that's
what's wild about Bernie right
if Bernie - Bernie fans it's like just
stand up for this like a broken watch is
Right twice a day
just because Trump said this doesn't
mean have to disagree cuz they're
clearly [ __ ] you disassociate himself
with Trump so bad well not just that - I
think he's his ideas no matter what the
Democratic Party needs to be the one
that wins so he doesn't want to [ __ ] on
his opponents so hard that if he's not
in the race in a more they can't win but
that's part of the problem right instead
of calling out Biden's corruption and
all the [ __ ] that's that's happening
there he is being a good boy and being
like my friend Joe Biden my friend he's
my good friend
Hillary after she [ __ ] the polls actly
and he and he was told on the phone
Donna Brazile told him that hey sorry we
did [ __ ] you over i keep that politician
money it's a better look than then the
Republicans being able to be like haha
look at the little Democrats fighting
like it's kind of better for him to just
kind of stand back but that's all he
doesn't like stoop to that usually
debates the price like the primaries
like they're all fighting each other
until they get their person and then
it's Republican versus look that's the
thing that's theater about all this
right so like no matter who wins if as
long as they're an establishment
candidate like the Warrens like the
Biden's then the old guard still rules
the same [ __ ] happened I didn't have the
most campaign contributions from
corporations and everyone of course not
I by far not to mention by credit card
company they want Biden to win yes and
the most small donations have been to
burn like to the brain no no yeah but
isn't making a ton of money from like
corporate
whoa yes yes those are the cuz I mean
you follow the money you know clearly
where the special interests are right so
I'm just going back to chasing like what
the question of what C and ends like
whole point is like status quo
I mean defend the wrong game defend the
work anima they're trying to win so why
would they help warrant or is in the mix
is he are they trying to [ __ ] Warren and
by our ratings that's what I feel like
they're trying to do they're chasing
ratings way more than anything but
Warren is not an anti-establishment
candidate Warren is totally corporatists
so is she with with the veil of she's
Bernie she was a Republican [ __ ] 12
what is it 20 years ago if that 18 my
question is where is Ralph Nader bring
back Nader he's gone bring back Nader no
bring him back
I had a Nader pin when I was in middle
school and my teacher was like what the
[ __ ] I believed in him she still does
he's an American Hero
yeah I really don't know that much about
Nader I just know he did I get what he
do yeah like all the all the vehicle
standards and stuff like all the seat
belts in cars from seat belts and stuff
and he's demanded that the the auto
industry's like put them in every car
and there was a big fight about that and
he was one of the main driving forces
behind that [ __ ] man American politics
is crazy though cuz when I was in Europe
everyone's watching our [ __ ] like
everyone you know and what else is crazy
is a lot of Asians overseas like in in
London or whatever they're like hey what
do you think about Andrew yang what do
you think about Andrew like everyone's
watching his [ __ ] cuz it affects their
all other countries this is what I was
telling people months ago I was like
look I know what you guys are saying
with yang but the DNC will never let him
win and it's the same [ __ ] as Tulsi
right yeah they dropped her out of the
debates the same [ __ ] because she is not
anti-war like she hates the Syria war
like she hates the Iraq war and she
bought there so people like to paint her
as a Russian asset and she's a
militating disrespect a [ __ ] well not
only she's an active military personnel
so there
disrespecting her and she's she's in her
service yeah she's in service try not to
do she will she's in reserve or whatever
right well she she comes back like and
does her work and then she's doing her
politics and implicit Warren is a Marine
and they're accusing her of being Mossad
spyer's
apologists yeah for Moosa Assad Assad
yeah there's the day that we're talking
about the DNC excuse me who's the they
yeah that dance fancy that that's well
no not just the establishment so who is
the establishment I think that's what we
need to answer so I think it's a big
group of people that are in cahoots
one is the military-industrial complex
meaning everyone that can profit from
war Republican and Democrat yeah it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
desert a game a big show
yeah because how does our milimeters our
military make money so the military
makes money by government contracts
right and the more wars were in the more
weapons we need to buy the more things
we need to do the more bases we need to
establish to keep things safe and on top
of that all the contracts that are tied
to the military construction contracts
like little military bases that need to
exist in these different countries and
once we just destabilize a nation a lot
of big corporations can move in and now
we have our banking systems there we
have our McDonald's there we have a lot
of things that are American corporations
that can exist in these country wholly
disabled as a nation Steve and Joe the
CIA and and with sanctions and yeah will
be outsourced now called economic hitmen
but all this stuff is really it sounds
crazy it's a lot of information that I'm
just briefly letting you know but all
these people who profit from it this is
a business right so in order for them to
keep their business viable and in order
for them to start keep building more
money making more money they need to be
in more wars so how do you get to war
you hire politicians and you keep them
wanting to get into work how do you get
to war how do you sell warded American
public you manufacture a narrative ie
weapons of mass destruction doesn't have
to be true or not and then nobody in the
intelligence community gets held
accountable right because they don't
need to because they're part of the game
and they get thanked for it actually and
promoted right and moved on to private
government contract jobs later on in
their careers so they all get shuffled
around and meanwhile we're all told to
get pissed at each other while we are
all in the same like socioeconomic
status yeah but the people who get
elected in the government leave with 90
million dollars or more like that's what
we should all be pissed about government
employees and Congress people who get
elected and leave richer yeah because
these corporations that they helped out
afterwards they're promised a contract
at their jobs a nice job Clinton do what
did George Dobie Bush do what did Obama
do Obama even talk [ __ ] on giving speech
presidential speeches after and getting
huge corporate donations for it yeah and
guess what he did the same [ __ ] he's out
there doing the corporate tour getting
millions of dollars to just go talk to a
company for 30 minutes and we're all
supposed to go yes that's worth their
time there was definitely nothing
happening in government where you were
helping these corporations get certain
things passed or certain things not
passed or not looked at while promised
later on hey you come give us a 30
minute speech and we'll give you
millions of dollars for it and that's
how you clean your money News
correspondent Bose coming in to say that
it sounds like all of the rich people
are treating us like little puppets even
though we're all in the same boat it's
almost like they put on a show for the
puppets and we all sit in the audience
and going mmm I think I have control
over this that person in the same row as
me is bad and then we look at the
politicians who are who are reaping and
sowing on top of us and go that's my
hero
that's my messiah save my love I want to
wear a shirt mm-hmm and that's the
[ __ ] game so unless you vote for
anti-establishment candidates you'll
just you you won't you it'll be it's
crazy it's like I'm predicting the
future right now you'll get more of the
same don't go rob a this year Brydon
Nader vote for Nader Zinaida already
dead is he dead put on the banner done
this is ended on such a Saturday
[Music]
[Music]